ce sont les valeurs de la république
c'est l'égalité des droits à l'égalité
des chances la juste récompense du
mérite et du travail c'est la solidarité
c'est la laïcité c'est la tolérance
e
alors je m'attèle philippe lambert je
suis comptable chez 26 en test le pacte
républicain pacte républicain ça veut
dire rassemblement ça veut dire efforts
pour faire en sorte que la cohésion
sociale de la société française qui est
menacée à cause de ces 5 millions
d'exclus notamment qu'a engendré le
phénomène du chômage faire en sorte donc
que cette cohésion soit préservée et
renforcée pour cela il faut se situer un
peu au dessus des clivages traditionnels
il faut essayer de rechercher ce qui
rassemble et non pas ceux qui divisent
vous avez observé que depuis le début de
sa campagne jacques chirac parle des
valeurs c'est un broc un peu disparu du
langage politique il parle des valeurs
républicaines
l'égalité des chances la récompense du
mérite et de l'effort individuel mais
aussi la solidarité la tolérance la
laïcité et ces valeurs là on le voit
bien
elles sont au dessus des clivages
traditionnels elles sont ni de droite ni
de gauche
ce sont des valeurs de rassemblement
elle fonde le pacte républicain
vous souhaitez vous dire aux sceptiques
aux personnes qui pensent qu'on ne peut
rien changé aujourd'hui
bon je souhaite leur dire que si depuis
le début de l'humanité
on avait toujours tenu ce raisonnement
nous en serions toujours la cro magnon
en fait depuis le début de l'humanité
il a toujours fallu remettre en cause
l'ordre établi pour progresser donc je
crois que la vraie question c'est de
savoir si on a la volonté de le faire et
si ayant la volonté on a les moyens mais
pas les moyens seulement techniques
financiers budgétaire les moyens humains
et les moyens humains c'est quoi c'est
le courage et l'imagination et mon
sentiment qui me laissait que
aujourd'hui d'une certaine façon le
courage l'imagination ont déserté les
hommes politiques et les dirigeants se
gagnent it's in ya quelques années du
temps que c'était encore la russie
soviétique trouvé que les occidentaux ne
faisait rien pour libérer les peuples
asservis et il disait dans son grand
discours harvard que le courage avait
déserté l'occident et bien d'une
certaine façon aujourd'hui je crois que
ce dont nous avons besoin c'est que le
courage habite de nouveau nos coeurs et
nos énergies
je pense que c'est ça le peuple attendre
cette élection présidentielle il attend
que ça ne soit pas après l'élection
comme avant et pour que ce ne soit pas
après comme avant eh bien je crois qu'il
faut d'abord c'est que on est une
volonté qu'on la met en oeuvre à partir
de beaucoup de courage comme jacques
chirac l'a fait quand il ya deux ans
personne ne croyait en lui il ne s'est
pas désunie il ne sait pas désolé il n'a
pas pleurnicher
il s'est pas mis à se lamenter en disant
tout le monde est méchant avec moi non
il a dit moi je connais ce que veulent
les français
j'ai le sentiment profond de leurs
besoins de leurs aspirations alors je
vais essayer de faire quelque chose et
puis aujourd'hui les français disent oui
on est d'accord pour faire un bilan
je m'appelle michael pasquet je suis
étudiant en médecine à à bobigny comment
pensez vous mettre fin à la mainmise des
politiques sur les médias la réponse est
laid comme dans tous les domaines c'est
le pluralisme qui n'entend qu'une cloche
d'antan conscient et c'est ce que dit la
sagesse populaire et donc il faut qu'on
puisse écouter toutes les pensées toutes
les paroles que chacun puisse s'exprimer
et dans cette campagne un exemple
absolument formidable c'est vrai que
pendant dans l'immédiat ont donné le
sentiment que la campagne se réduisait
ya d'un côté une candidature de gauche
de témoignage parce que la gauche
personne n'en voulait et de l'autre côté
un premier ministre candidat officiel
qui allait passer de la rive gauche à la
rive droite et d'un fauteuil à matignon
à un fauteuil à l'elysée mais comme par
une espèce de formalité électorale et
les français ont dit mais nous c'est pas
ça l'élection présidentielle c'est nous
nous voulons utiliser l'élection
présidentielle pour faire changer les
choses
et comme vous même moment jacques chirac
leur disais exactement la même chose
ils ont dit lui il nous prend vraiment
au sérieux et c'est comme ça qu'on a
brisé si j'ose dire
le conformisme des médias donc je pense
que il ya deux réponses
la première réponse et assurer le
pluralisme et la deuxième réponse c'est
dire des choses vraies et forte
et quand on dit des choses vraies forte
et bien le finissent toujours par passer